digamos que me he ganado un concurso en
algún lugar de venta de coches y me van
a regalar un auto para que ellos puedan
seleccionar el tipo de auto que me van a
dar porque finalmente es un regalo
tienen dos tipos de motores de los
cuales podemos
elegir y esto va a ser al azar así es
que solo tenemos dos opciones tenemos
autos con motores de cuatro cilindros
o autos con motores de seis cilindros
recuerda que esta selección va a ser
completamente al azar y tenemos
oportunidades iguales ahora también nos
van a dar un color vamos a poner el
color
algo neutro
y las posibilidades de color que me
pueden dar de auto pueden ser rojo me
gustan los coches rojos de hecho
rojo
azul
verde
o blanco
y digamos que mi ideal va a ser un auto
de seis cilindros con color blanco qué
posibilidades tengo de que esto suceda
dado que todas son posibilidades iguales
y los invito a que ustedes pausa en el
vídeo para que lo intenten por su parte
lo que haremos es
buscan la probabilidad de tener un auto
de 6 cilindros blanco y lo haremos a
través de un diagrama de árbol así que
lo primero que haremos es utilizar la
información del motor y saber que
nosotros tendremos entonces dos
posibilidades un auto
de cuatro cilindros o un auto de seis
cilindros y si quiero pensar las
posibilidades dentro de los motores de
cuatro cilindros pues pudiéramos tener
un auto de cuatro cilindros de color
rojo
uno azul
1 verde
y un auto de cuatro cilindros de color
blanco
pero si pensamos en un auto de 6
cilindros pues también tendremos la
posibilidad de tener un auto de 6
cilindros rojo
uno azul
1 verde
seis cilindros color verde
o un auto de 6 cilindros color blanco
que finalmente el que nosotros estamos
buscando es este vamos a preguntarnos si
nosotros tuviésemos este auto sería de
cuatro cilindros color verde o tal vez
éste sería de seis cilindros color azul
lo que nosotros estamos buscando es este
el de seis cilindros
color blanco y para eso podemos saber
que hay ocho posibilidades uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho ocho
posibilidades iguales de tener este auto
blanco de seis cilindros y estamos
considerando que para el color hicieron
una rifa de poner en un papel cada uno
de estos colores y simplemente al azar
sacarían uno con ello podemos llegar
entonces a la conclusión que tenemos una
de ocho oportunidades para que nuestro
auto sea de seis cilindros con color
blanco ahora también podemos pensarlo
desde otro punto de vista qué pasa si
nosotros tomamos como inicio los colores
nuestro auto pudiera ser rojo o pudiera
ser azul
azul
también quedamos que puede ser verde
todos y cada uno de estos colores tienen
la misma posibilidad
y finalmente también pudiera ser blanco
si nosotros también pensamos que un auto
color rojo va a tener un tipo de motor
que puede ser de cuatro o de seis
cilindros entonces marcaremos esas
posibilidades aquí puede ser rojo de
cuatro cilindros o rojo de seis
cilindros puede ser azul de cuatro
cilindros o puede ser azul de seis
cilindros también puede ser verde de
cuatro cilindros o verde de seis
cilindros de la misma manera que puede
ser blanco de cuatro cilindros o blanco
de seis cilindros y con esto también
podemos hacer las mismas preguntas que
teníamos hace un rato por ejemplo este
sería un auto azul de cuatro cilindros o
este pudiera ser un auto verde de seis
cilindros nosotros nos vamos a enfocar
en este nosotros queremos saber qué
probabilidad tenemos de tener un auto
blanco de seis cilindros y entonces
volvemos a contar las posibilidades que
tenemos que todas son iguales y son 12
4 5 6 7 8 una vez más tenemos una de 8
posibilidades dado que primero tenemos
el color y después el tipo de motor
en ambos casos tenemos una de ocho
posibilidades de tener el auto de 6
cilindros color blanco que tanto
queremos y esto se debe a que tenemos
cuatro posibles colores y dos tipos
posibles de motor